get off of me lady get off of me oh god
I think she might be dead what was that
noise oh my [ __ ] go got hit by a car
I swim there nice swim hey slim look at
my sweet goat spinning ability how do I
get out of here use this pipe what the
hell [ __ ] ninja turtles get away from
me Nick you Donatello straight up have
the ninja turtles in here Thursday all
right airhead [ __ ] Michael Bay turtle
haha specifically the Michael Bay
turtles go away from me I take you with
me yeah techamerica come with me gonna
show you the wonders at the outside
world and introduce you to my friend
April O'Neil is he gone is he gone fancy
ghazal i love the beds casa get em away
go the only way to enter a bouncy castle
is to a different bouncing apparatus ah
i meant believe trampoline Oh
stop stop yep nailed it I jump in this I
gonna jump in this roller coaster when
it passes by there we go yeah that's not
I don't think this is really wall
running is there a real thing on this
all there is look at it here we go yeah
[ __ ] tried to lick it I tried to lick
it come on go back go back go back go
back come back come back come back do it
you can do a lan there and I'm there
yeah nailed it on I can do it I go any
higher I'm gonna have to time this
perfectly [ __ ]
oh go first went alright is this [ __ ]
ball right go brighter whoa yeah get the
[ __ ] what what I'm not okay with this
well my lady enjoying your time at the
fair grounds are you enjoying your time
at the fairground oh yes what does my
mom asks for what I do for them he's
gonna Center this in future Maureen
cliff jumps yeah now your goat in it and
then yep
you made stupidly wide
yep it's definitely cutting her do it
gate Borden
jump oh no uh negative yes yes all of my
dreams have come true hey oh [ __ ] I'm so
glad I'm so good that don't get caught
off stay on it stay on it stay on it you
stupid yep hey on it was a [ __ ] party
on up here jump me off this can I my
talk disengage the tongue yes it's my
birthday party what the artist game is
just keeps getting weirder and weirder
lets me and my boy dead matters and
we're just yeah mesmo all right like
that master freaking that mess but he's
so good doesn't fall over all you can
tell because i'm s-sorry that nice and
all of you guys you need anything music
by yourself is fine
Jesus Christ what happens fireworks oh
it's up don't worry to meet that mess
yep deadmau5 meet deadmau5 come with me
to my concert dude hey it's me I'm back
yeah y'all back down today all right
about that yeah get off like this is my
party it off like that for you my party
I bought it it's up party yeah just like
Tony hold on these are slow boat easy
game the system is sick manual work
rodney Mullen ain't got [ __ ] on me oh
that invisible wall is son of a [ __ ]
video game no way is this invisible wall
go put it's a [ __ ] invisible wall
let's push me back bring me to the
Paradise thing
secret island
go
I couldn't get out here by my own means
hahahahaha what's out here the secret
autumn has to be something here is that
thing lick it lick it whoo I tried some
shrooms what could go wrong my [ __ ]
raccoon now what's up what I need some
more mushrooms right okay mushrooms are
delicious I better keep eating them Lee
delicious mushrooms perhaps this has
gone a bit weird cuz cuz I'm not wearing
I'm I'm not using the actual original
goat skin but this mushroom get all the
mushrooms
my other is big now keep doing this we
can keep licking these delicious
mushrooms